COMING UP A "HANNITY" NOW.
♪ ♪
>> Sean: WELCOME TO THE BIG
BREAKING NEWS ADDITION OF
"HANNITY," HELLO MIAMI!
WE BEGIN TONIGHT A FOX NEWS
ALERT AND TONIGHT THE WITCH HUNT
THE SCHUMER SHIFT SHAM SHOW, IT
IS THANKFULLY FOR THE SICK OF
THE COUNTRY, THE UNITED STATE
SENATOR DENIED THE DEMOCRATS
LATEST WITNESS AND THE VOTE TO
ACQUIT THE PRESIDENT IS NOW
INEVITABLE AND WE WILL TAKE
PLACE AND KNOW WE EXPECT
4:00 P.M. WEDNESDAY AFTERNOON
AND THE COUNTRY CAN NOW
HOPEFULLY FINALLY MOVE ON FROM
THE BACK FREAK, PARTISAN
IMPEACHMENT SHAM THAT WILL GO
DOWN IN HISTORY AS ONE OF THE
BIGGEST AND SINGLE MOST
EMBARRASSING DEMOCRATIC BLUNDERS
OF ALL TIME.
NOW, A THREE YEAR LONG AND NEVER
ENDING TEMPER TANTRUM, IT WILL
BE OVER WEDNESDAY AND THE DAMAGE
TO THE COUNTRY AS OF TONIGHT AND
CALCULABLE.
THE LAST SAME PEOPLE, RUSSIA,
PRUSSIA, RUSSIA, IMPEACH,
COLLUSION, COLLUSION, THREE
YEARS OF THIS, THOSE THAT
ADVANCED THEIR CONSPIRACY
THEORIES ALMOST DAILY, THOSE
THAT TOTALLY IGNORED WHAT WAS
THE BIGNESS OF SIGNAL ABUSE OF
POWER CORRUPTION SCANDAL IN
HISTORY, THOSE WHO IGNORE THE
DIRTY DOSSIER, PREMEDITATED
FRAUD ON THE PFIZER COURT TO
DENY ONE AMERICAN HIS CIVIL
LIBERTIES, CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHTS, THOSE WERE FOR SPYING ON
A PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE
ILLEGALLY AND THE TRANSITION
TEAM.
LEADING INTO THE TRUMPET AND
THIS IS A PERIOD
OF SAME PEOPLE, OF COURSE THE
ALLIES IN THE MEDIAL MOB, AND
THEY FEEL THAT WHAT THAT WAS THE
LATEST COUP ATTEMPT AND THEY’VE
NOT LIFTED A SINGLE FINGER AT AL
TO HELP YOU, WE THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE, CREATE A SINGLE JOB,
THEY DID NOT MAKE US ANY MORE
SAFE OR SECURE OR PROSPEROUS.
THEY HAVE DRAG THIS OUT, BEING
THEIR USUAL IMMATURE CELLS,
CLEARLY, THEIR HATRED OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP NOW SURPASSES
THEIR DECIPHER TO DO ANYTHING FO
AMERICAN PEOPLE AS
EVIDENCED BY THE LAST THREE
YEARS AND THIS IS ACTUALLY A SAD
AND A VERY DANGEROUS CHAPTER AND
WE ARE CLOSING IN THIS COUNTRY’S
HISTORY.
EARLIER TODAY, SENATE MAJORITY
LEADER MITCH McCONNELL HE
SECURED THE PHOTO BLOCK FURTHER
WITNESSES AND PREVENT FURTHER
DISTRACTION.
HE DID NOT TAKE ON WHAT’S THE
SOUL CONSTITUTION ROLE OF THE
HOUSE TO IMPEACH AND BY THE WAY,
THE END IS IN SIGHT, IT CANNOT
BE SOON ENOUGH AND THE G.O.P.
SENATORS, LAMAR ALEXANDER, AND
THE OPPOSITION, TO THE
DEMOCRATS LATEST LAST-MINUTE
HAIL MARY OR WHAT?
MORE WITNESSES?
WE HAD THE OPINION WITNESSES,
HEARSAY WITNESSES, THE ONLY ONE
FACT WITNESSES AND WENT TO THE
PRESIDENT WANT?
NO, NO QUADE OR PRO OR QUOTE,
THEY DID EXACTLY WHAT THE
UNITED STATES CONSTITUTION AS
THEY REALLY POINTED OUT REQUIRED
SENATOR MURKOWSKI RELEASED THE
STATEMENT VERY POWERFUL.
"AT THE HOST JUSTICES END OF THE
ARTICLES OF IMPEACHMENT THAT ARE
RUSHED AND FLAWED AND I
CAREFULLY CONSIDERED THE NEED
FOR ADDITIONAL WITNESSES AND
DOCUMENTS TO CURE THE
SHORTCOMINGS OF THE PROCESS AND
ULTIMATELY DECIDED THAT I WILL
VOTE AGAINST MOTIONS TO
SUBPOENA."
LAST NIGHT,
SENATOR LAMAR ALEXANDER TWEETING
THIS IS A SHALLOW AND WHOLLY
PARTISAN IMPEACHMENT WERE TO
SUCCEED, IT WOULD RIP THE
COUNTRY APART FOR A GASOLINE ON
THE FIRE OF CULTURAL DIVISION
THAT ALREADY EXISTS.
IT WOULD CREATE THE WEAPON USED
AGAINST FUTURE PRESIDENTS
WHENEVER THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES ON A DIFFERENT
POLITICAL PARTY.
THANK YOU FOR STANDING FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, THANK YOU FOR
STANDING FOR TRUTH, FOR FACTS,
FOR FAIRNESS, THANK YOU FOR
STANDING AGAINST WHAT IS A RAGE
FUELED A PARTISAN WITCH HUNT.
THANK YOU FOR STANDING FOR OUR
CONSTITUTION.
ANY EFFORT TO EXTEND THEIR
CHARADE IT ANY LONGER IS NOT A